I'm Gary Stevenson
formertrader and people's economist
this is Gary's Economics and today
we're here at Oxford University to
talk about the big question everybody's
asking; why are economists always wrong?
in 2005 when i was 18 i started studying
economics at the London School of Economics
that's one of the top economics universities
in the world i studied economic theory there
for three years before going into the city
in 2008 when a financial crisis happened
when i was there our job was to predict when will
the economy recover now in 2008 we predicted 2009
in 2009 we predicted 2010, in 2010 we predicted
2011 and at the beginning of 2020 last year
we were still predicting a recovery later that
year and it wasn't just the traders in the markets
the economists here at Oxford University
were predicting the same thing
so economists all over the world in all the
governments and at the Bank of England too
now this is a really really big problem right
economists are the guys whose job it is to fix
economic problems now if we've got an economic
problem that keeps getting worse and worse and
worse but these guys constantly think things are
about to get better then they are not going to fix
that problem right that means things will
continue to get worse for ordinary people
so this is a big problem which we need
to address so we've come here today
to Oxford University to address this question
why is it that economists are always wrong?
this is the Oxford University Economics
department, I studied here from 2017 to 2 019.
now when i was here we had the lecturer teach us
a lecture on interest rates which is exactly the
product i traded and made millions of pounds
trading because economists all over the world
incorrectly predicted a recovery for 10 years
in a row after the lecture i went up to the
lecturer and said look can we talk about why it
was that economist got this so wrong for so long
and he said to me like no that didn't happen we
always know interest rates were going to stay
low we knew it would be a long recovery and you
know i didn't even know what to say when he said
that because you know i'd been watching this as
a job you know for like the previous like six
seven years of my life i knew he wasn't right and
i said you know that's not right you got it wrong
he didn't believe it so i said don't worry
i'll go i'll send you the data i sent the data
and he said "oh yeah that's interesting" but this
guy is a professor teaching interest rates at
Oxford University and he doesn't realize that
these guys have predicted it incorrectly for 10
years in a row like that is crazy right not only
are these guys so bad that their predictions are
wrong 10 years in a row they are so bad that they
don't even realise they're bad they don't realise
they've made those wrong predictions okay so why
did that happen all right in order to illustrate
why that happened i brought in some of the work
i did when i was here okay so this is my folder
when i was here at oxford and let's look at what
a typical economic student does oxford university
you can see there it's a nice page of
algebra we'll go to another page there
there you go it's a slightly shorter page
of algebra we'll flip through a bit shall we
another page of algebra we'll flip
towards the end more algebra and you
know i could keep going through this algebra
so much so i had to turn the pitch sideways
algebra algebra algebra that's all we're doing
here if you thought that we were talking about
the housing crisis we're not if you thought we're
talking about why your wages don't go up we're not
if you thought we're talking about why you can't
get a good job in the city where you grew up
we're not all we're doing is algebra algebra
algebra now i found this very frustrating
and to be honest i used to get quite angry
when i was here and one of the professors
asked me you know why are you so angry and
i said i'm angry because you're not talking
about what's happening in people's lives you know
why are you not talking about the housing crisis
and he said to me we don't talk about the housing
crisis because it's only in London which its not
by the way but I said to him look the housing
crisis is only in London because that's where
the jobs are people have to move to London that's
where the jobs are and he said that's not true
i've got a job, this guy is a macroeconomics
professor at oxford university so you're telling
me like some guy's lost his job in Grimsby
or in Wigan or in Stoke or in Cardiff
you're going to turn around to them and say oh
don't worry have you thought about being a
macroeconomics professor at Oxford university
yeahit's madness and it shouldn't be acceptable
so let's talk about how is it that this
person thinks it's acceptable to say this
this is Keble College, Oxford this was my college
when i studied here this is the kind of place
where economics professors and students might
come in the evening wearing their bow ties and
their capes and have a fancy dinner in a harry
potter dining hall now the thing you need to
know about economics is that it is the least
socially diverse of all major subjects in phd
it has the highest number of students who have
parents from privileged backgrounds and the
lowest number of students who have parents from
ordinary backgrounds what this means is when these
guys make predictions that are incorrect they are
not the ones that get hurt when house prices go up
that's okay that's okay because their families
own a lot of property when wages fall that's okay
because their wages don't fall when inequality
goes up they are the group that is getting richer
rather than the  big group which is getting poorer
these guys are not affected by the incorrect
predictions but not only that the fact that they
are so separated from ordinary society means they
are unable to understand what's happening in the
last 13 years the main problem has been not enough
people spending money and the economists here
they don't understand why that's happening now
i know the people watching understand why that's
happening ordinary people understand but when
i asked an economist here what did he say? I said
why are people not spending money and he said we
don't really know but we think it's because of an
exogenous shock to consumption savings preferences
that's what he said an exogenous shock
to consumption savings preferences now
you don't need to understand what that means
to know that's nonsense you know because i've
asked a lot of people why they're not
spending and nobody ever said it was
because of the exogenous shock to their
consumption savings preferences okay so
this guy is so disconnected he cannot even
understand why ordinary people don't spend
more money okay now listen when i worked at
Citibank i was lucky enough to work with a
fantastically intelligent trader who didn't
go to university he just came from an ordinary
background in Liverpool and worked his way
up to the top which you can't really do now
when i worked with him i used to bring my
textbooks in to study economics to try and
understand what's happening and one day he came
over he just took those textbooks and he threw
them in a bin and he said gary look if you want to
understand the economy go and talk to your parents
talk to your friends and their families understand
the economic situation ask what's happening to
them walk down the high street see what shops are
closing down see if there's more homelessness you
know look at the adverts on the tube and on the
street that is gonna teach you what's happening
in the economy all right look everybody
watching this video i want you to understand
you are the economy your family is the
economy your communities are the economy
your economic problems are the economic problems
and those are the things that people here should
be talking about but look around you do you
think those are the things that these people
are worried about they're not because when
inequality increases those people get richer
their lives don't get worse they *get*better
so they can predict wrong as much as they
like they've still got comfortable lives they're
still getting paid their families and communities
are still doing perfectly well the economists here
don't understand why people aren't spending money
but i understand and you understand we
understand because we are ordinary people
from ordinary families we know what's happening
these guys don't understand because they're not
ordinary people from ordinary families are not
spending more money because they are not getting
any more money because that money is flowing to
the rich and these guys here wearing their bow
ties and teaching in castles are not going to
help us and a chancellor who is a billionaire
is not going to help us and a prime minister who
is a multi-millionaire is not going to help us we
have to help us we have to make it happen and the
way we do that is by educating ourselves and each
other about economics by teaching each other that
the key thing we need to fix is wealth inequality
by teaching each other that if we don't fix
wealth inequality things are not going to
get better but we'll get worse but if we do fix
it things can get so much better for all of us
so please go watch what is wealth educate
yourselves teach your friends teach your family
tell them what's happening the only way we are
going to get better lives for ordinary families
is by fixing wealth inequality so
tell each other what's happening
anyway it's nearly time for dinner so I
gotta go put my bow tie on, keep watching
but poorer families will be forcedto lose almost
all of their assetsincluding their home
we have a tax system which isvery efficient
at taxing ordinary working people
but very inefficient at taxing the super rich